while continuing our rattling through
leaders of political parties the local
elections are also of course a crucial
shock window for the greens
climate change dominating the news in
the run-up to cop late last year but has
a focus on the cost of living in ukraine
pushed it down the agenda well we can
speak now to the leader a co-leader i
should say of the green party agent
ramsey thank you very much for being
with us
so what would success look like for the
green party next week
well the green party has trebled its
number of councillors across the country
in recent years more greens leading
change in our communities and seats
we've won from all the other parties
right across the country so success this
time will mean more greens elected right
across the country we're confident that
will be from labor and the conservatives
we're confident we'll see big strides
forward including in places where we
already have good numbers of councillors
and expect to see more places like
reading and burnley and south tyneside
and also other places where there's
currently not a strong challenge to the
incumbent so if you look at london
boroughs like islington like newham like
hackney where there's very little
challenge to the labour administration
greens are actively challenging on the
ground and look to get
we look set to get opposition
councillors elected to be having a green
in the room that can make a big
difference to the debate as well as
being champions for local communities
it does feel like sorry uh one of the
quiet stories of the last few years has
been the steady improvement of the green
party and you made a neck
sorry excuse me
uh the green's been a net gain of 88
councillors for example in 2021.
at the same time though this has been
off the back of labour doing slightly
disappointingly in the polls are you not
concerned that as labour
comes into a stronger
performance that in the polls ahead of
these elections it could be at the
expense of you
the response we're getting on the
doorstep is that at a time when we're
seeing so many schedules in westminster
people are looking for an alternative to
the established political parties and
a fresh voice
to provide an alternative to that
establishment and that's what greens are
offering practical improvements that can
make a real difference to people's
everyday lives as well as a healthier
environment and we have made a real
progress against labor as you say and
interestingly in last year's local
elections as you say record gains for
the greens most of which were actually
gains from the conservatives so we are
winning from all the other parties right
across the country and we're confident
of more strides forward this time round
i just wanted to talk a little bit about
your foreign policy because it feels as
if the
defense and foreign policy land shape
has completely shifted this year with
the invasion of ukraine
with russia of course a country with
nuclear weapons being so aggressive in
its invasion of another
country
as well and many of those countries nato
members included places like poland
being very concerned about their own
security going forward
did the greens still want to take the
united kingdom out of nato
so we have a long-term policy that's
about reviewing what structures we need
to have to build peace in the world and
we have to remember this conflict has
happened at the time when we're part of
nato and where
where we still see nuclear weapons
dominate
of course we're not about changing
structures in the middle of a conflict
and what we need to do at the moment is
focus on how ukraine can be supported in
a wide variety of ways and that needs to
mean a greater focus on peacekeeping and
on getting the parties to the table
we're pleased the united nations has
started to do that but there needs to be
far more focus on bringing the parties
around the table and there needs to be
stronger economic action as well because
across europe we're still sending a
billion euros a day to vladimir putin's
war machine from buying russian oil gas
and coal and we need to wean ourselves
off this addiction as of course greens
want us to do if we're to avoid funding
that war machine and really put strong
economic pressure on russia and that's
really got to be stepped up
and you said a lot in that um answer but
i didn't actually catch the answer to
the question itself which was do the
green party still want to take the
united kingdom out of nato i think i did
answer that sophie which is that yes
that is our long-term policy that we
would like to see
far greater focus on peacekeeping
institutions and institutions that
support
a reduction in our nuclear weapons and
and
countries moving away from nuclear
weapons
but in the short term of course we're
not proposing moving out of nato in the
middle of a conflict the focus needs to
be on international action that brings
pressure to bear on russia through a
variety of means including the work of
the united nations including um
international cooperation in a variety
of ways and that must mean economic
pressure on russia through sanctions on
oil and gas
okay thank you uh very much uh the
leader co-leader of the green party
thank you